uh well let's bring you up to date now
with the latest covert data that we've
just received in relation to
cover deaths and we are seeing i'm
afraid to say
the highest number of daily deaths since
the pandemic began
with a total of one thousand hundred 325
deaths recorded
in the last 24 hours that's up from 1162
yesterday and beat the previous record
of 1224
on the 21st of april last year
daily cases are up as well 60 053
reported in the last 24 hours up
from 52 618 yesterday we've got a
statement from
public health england in relation to
those shocking
death numbers dr william welfare
director for the covert 19 response at
phe
england said each life loss to this
virus is a tragedy
but sadly we can expect the death toll
to continue to rise until we stop the
spread
approximately one in three people who
have coronavirus have no symptoms and
could be spreading it without realizing
it
he goes on to say to protect our loved
ones it is essential we all stay safe at
home where possible
this will reduce new infections and ease
the pressure on the nhs
and save lives let's get some analysis
of those figures from skies
adele robinson and adele whether or not
that is attributable to
the new variant or the fact that people
were mixing over the festive period
they are stark figures nonetheless
they are um i think it was what we were
all worried about and perhaps what we
were all expecting as well though as you
say
um we have now had the highest
number of deaths daily deaths since the
start of the pandemic just to reiterate
what you've been saying there
within the last day that 24 hours there
have been 1
325 deaths um
that's deaths of people who've been have
died within 28 days of a positive covid
19
deaths that's uh surpassed
the highest number which was on the 21st
of april
which was 1224 so surpassed it by
a fair bit um yesterday we saw the
second highest that was 1162 so the new
updated daily figure for deaths is 1325
within 28 days of a positive covid19
test also the number of people
testing positive as well 68 053
uh which again incredibly high has
jumped from yesterday
um the reasons that it all jumped from
yesterday
that there's often a lag at this time of
year because of bank holidays and the
holiday period
so sometimes it's easy to get caught up
in the the daily inc
decreases or increases when it comes to
testing
it just depends on how that's been
reported in the last couple of weeks in
the last few
days but very high nonetheless it's the
11th day that it's actually been above
50 000 cases and i say not surprising
because of the news
elsewhere that we've heard today such as
london hospitals to collect declaring
a critical incident and they join a
number of other hospitals across the
country
which are struggling to cope with the
sheer number of patients
being admitted and as you say there was
this
statement issued uh from the director
for the kovid 19 response at public
health england let me just
uh repeat that he says each life lost to
this virus is a tragedy
but sadly we can expect the death toll
to continue to rise
until we stop the spread approximately
one in three people who have coronavirus
have
no symptoms and could be spreading it
without realizing it
to protect our loved ones it's essential
we all stay home where possible
this will reduce new infections ease the
pressure on the nhs
and save lives so a stark warning there
that
we can expect the death toll to continue
to rise above the highest
it's ever been since the start of the
pandemic the other statistics released
today
the r number which on the face of it um
it's compared with two weeks ago
has sort of stayed the same in that it's
an average across the country but the
upper end of the estimate has risen
and the reason for the slight
discrepancy on either end of this
r number it's now between one and one
point four two weeks ago is between one
point one and one point three
is because there is this regional uh
variation
uh there are there is a lag though um in
some of the data that's being that is
used to calculate the r number
and just to remind you the r number uh
basically the statistics today mean that
for every on average every 10 people
infected they'll go on to infect between
10 and 14 other people
but the data being used to come up with
that figure there is a lag
quite often in terms of hospital
admissions and some of the data that
they use icu admissions deaths
and so it can be a couple of weeks
before
it's up to date so the r number that
we'll see in a couple of weeks time
might be more reflective of where we're
at
at this particular moment in time so
it's important to remember that but
overall um the epidemic is increasing
regionally there are some differences it
looks like the southwest is seeing
um an estimated between 1.1 and 1.5
r number which is uh higher than the uk
average
and also the growth rate which looks at
how quickly the number of infections are
changing day by day
um across the uk it's between zero and
six percent
um but if you take the example of the
southwest
it's between two and eight percent
estimate
and in the midlands it's between one and
seven percent those two areas
looking like they are uh worst affected
in terms of the estimate for the growth
rate at the moment anyway uh but as i
said no surprise here um
a tragic and grim almost milestone
to have passed that we have surpassed
april's
death toll um today at 1
325 deaths within the last 24 hours
sad news adele thank you very much
indeed